so now we have a journey if I lost the
same question I did back there what was
the point of that yes I'm gonna put this
into y minus y1 equals M that's not X
minus x1 yes okay now keep in mind this
is a gradient function right so this
gives me the gradient anyway that may be
X and anyone but it what any X or any
why I want that X and that Y okay
so therefore the equation of the tangent
is what about is y1 is literally my I
minus y1 like that's the coordinates
okay but what I put in em I don't like
this this is a function it is a number
right
I want the gradient at the particular
value for X equal to X 1 and y equals y1
does that make sense
a lot of people just put this into M
that's not a number it's a function okay
so instead of that I'm going to put
minus B squared x1 it's an actual number
on a squared Y 1 it's a number okay and
then I've got my X minus x1 in there
okay and then when I simplify this do
why do you have a go see what your
numbers and this time I look at how she
put into general form
I want you to think about what might be
the neatest form the most convenient one
for the purpose of words what did i do
from first to second line yeah I need to
get rid of this fraction away right so
there you can see all of those terms
have gotten a spent y11 what did i do
from line to line three just
good so I've got the UM the X and the y
there and over here this is just one big
constant it's a gross constant but
that's all it is okay now at this point
is not obvious what I should do with
this okay so I'm gonna give you a bit of
a hand to try and make a little more
obvious on the right-hand side I am
going to factor out and number but you
see me do this before I'm going to break
the rules of factorizing and I love what
you're supposed to do is find out a
number that is in common between these
and they need to buy that room right
there is no single number that is common
to both of them do you see that they're
made up a completely different pieces
but that's okay because if I take out
this there's part in common with the
first and then planned common with the
second term do you agree with that
what's gonna happen is I lose the B
squared here but because I'm dividing
I'm multiplying by a squared well-fitted
survial on the inside so that would give
me this yeah and the same thing happens
for the y1 squared but in Reverse okay
so far so good
now when you do this when you do this
you look at that B on the right and you
stare it up and you stare it really hard
and you should say that looks familiar
in fact I've written that almost
identical thing on the board what does
that look like what does this look
similar to does that not look like the
equation or one side of the equation of
an ellipse do you see it right here
right
all I've done is I've changed X into X 1
and Y into y 1 but X 1 Y 1 is on the
ellipse it's a point that satisfies this
equation that's what it means to be on
the ellipse right so therefore I should
be able to put x1 y1 into here and this
will be a true statement
so therefore the right-hand side
really have is a squared times B squared
times 1 okay now that's a very kind
intuitive thing to see like that's more
obvious like doing this is not obviously
but now that you can see that we can
make this nice and neat
someone like tiny be suggestive of nice
step I could do that's gonna make it a
nice leap and I could divide by one if I
really wanted to I wouldn't get very
much out of it okay now do you see this
is a beautiful form look at that right
in fact do you remember bless you when
we were doing the paratroops of the
parabola we go things like this right
with the equation of the tangent looked
almost exactly the same as the equation
of the parabola itself but do you recall
that so what you've got here these
almost identical to this do you see how
similar it is I've just taken where the
X's turn the next one say for the one
now just to verify that we haven't just
like done some algebraic screw up okay
remember I know that x1 and y1 were just
by alternative labels for these guys
remember that the same thing so let's
just just see what happens what is a
sorry X is equal to a cos theta what
happened and y equals B Scythia watch
what happens as we substitute in for x1
x1 and y1 you see that over here I'm
gonna get x times a cos theta on a swim
and then here we're going to get Y times
B sine theta on these magnets to one
right cancel cancel cancel cancel boy
that looks familiar right so just to
verify you can see that the Cutty and
approach and the parametric approach do
give us the same result but I think this
is
ha and Messier whereas provided Yura
came in this idea this is much more
direct consider okay the algebra at
least is much easier
any questions on that yeah okay that is
the right question to ask and the answer
is was quite novel and I will show you
what I mean let's do an example together